من غابة مطيرة استوائية إلى
حافة الوقت نفسه ،
يبدأ جيمس ويب رحلة العودة إلى
الولادة ، حيث قام الكون
بإحداث ثقب في الغيوم بعد 20
ثانية من برنامج الطيران الجيد
(الموسيقى)
يمكننا سماع الضجيج والشعور
بالاهتزازات هنا.  إنه حقًا ، نعم ،
مثير للإعجاب إذا
نظرنا إلى الوراء في تلسكوب جيمس ويب الفضائي ،
هذا تأخير لمدة 20 ثانية
تقريبًا لأن الطريقة التي
تتم بها معالجة الصور هنا في غرفة التحكم ،
يوجد التلسكوب الخاص بك جاهزًا لفك
أجنحته بشكل أساسي والبدء في أه
رحلة إليها ، نقطة lagrange ، النقطة l2 على بعد
حوالي مليون ميل من
انقراض الأرض لآخر
رحلة في نهاية الرحلة والجزء الأخير
من
تلسكوب فضاء الويب المنفصل ، انتقل إلى الويب ،
لديك تأكيد لفصل المرصد
، تلسكوب james webb الفضائي  وسط
تصفيق هنا في مركز التحكم بالمهمة ،
يتخذ الآن خطواته الأولى في السعي وراء
الاكتشاف الكوني ،
وتذهب الصور الرائعة لهذا
التلسكوب بعيدًا.  o الويب
نعم اذهب بعيدًا
بشكل مثير للسخرية بما فيه الكفاية
يا روب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا كل شيء
[موسيقى
] وهناك هناك مكالمتك الحاسمة
جيمس ويب ليس فقط لديه أرجل ولكن
لديه القوة
لأنه يبدأ رحلته في عيد الميلاد
هدية لعلماء الفلك في العالم  بينما
يبدأ تلسكوب جيمس ويب الفضائي
حياته
متجهًا نحو ابتهاج عميق كهذا
هنا على الأرض بمعنى
تحكم المشتري